probably get going um
are you ready then i'll just make a
super short introduction
i'm ready yeah so we're not very formal
we're thinking of this if this were a
simon's workshop you'd have all of these
wonderful talks just in sequence now
we're spacing another one
one a week but but just by
a very uh brief introduction this is the
beyond
sat workshop in the context of sat i
mean it could be mentioned
i guess the two two two contexts in
which almond would be
cited um is for
er that he showed that in fact
conflict-driven close learning solvers
are have the potential to be as strong
as general resolution a question that
had been open for quite a while
i think it's also fair to say that
he is behind one of the popular
heuristics that is
these days more or less established
inside something maybe face saving i
think that's correct
um but of course adam's main claim to
fame
uh i'll try to keep this short but it
goes far beyond
sat even beyond np and in some sense
adnan was even
you know before we dreamt up this beyond
sat program
adnan was pitching beyond np and
organizing beyond the mp workshops
so giving inspirations to us and i think
what we might be hearing about today is
uh knowledge compilation and
representation in some sense maybe but i
won't guess i will
leave the floor to adnan and he will
tell us what he will talk about
very good uh thank you jacob all right
so uh the title beyond b with tractable
circuits
and um the idea is we're going to try to
target problems
that are beyond mp but in a systematic
fashion
using the theory of tractable circuits
so let me start with this slide which
actually uh sums up a lot of what we'll
be talking about today
so what we have here is complexity
classes okay so we
know np and there are classes that are
beyond that
um some are familiar pp now is pretty
popular that's the counting class and
and there are other classes and we're
interested in solving problems
uh in those classes if you look for
example at probabilistic reasoning
and machine learning i'm showing here a
picture of what's known as a bayesian
network
there are four classical or canonical
problems on these that people have been
working on for decades
and each one of these four happened to
be complete for one of these classes
we're going to take a look at that
now the interesting thing is if you look
at these classes the
prototypical problem for this class is
complete and
and represent these classes are all on
boolean formula
and also there is now
efficient very practical reductions that
can take some of these problems that i
mentioned here the four
canonical and write out boolean formulas
that correspond to these problems so we
can solve these now systematically
by solving the prototypical problems for
these classes which are all problems as
i said on boolean formula we're going to
take a look at these
in just a little bit now the question is
then how do we solve these problems how
do we solve these prototypical problems
for these classes which as i mentioned
are all
questions on boolean formulas and the
bulk of
the discussion today is that we can do
this systematically by compiling
the boolean formula to attractive
boolean circuits so what is the
tractable wooden circuit
it's just a boolean circuit in the
classical sense with some additional
properties on it
and as we add properties to these
circuits they start attaining names they
become distinct
creatures and as you'll see for example
as part of the theory of tractable
circuits we do know for each one of
these classes
we do know of a circuit class or a
property that if you put on a boolean
circuit
which allows you to solve that problem
in time linear in the circuit size so
what that means is you give me a boolean
formula that corresponds to one of these
problems you want to solve it
if i manage to compile it into
attractable circuit of an appropriate
type then i'm done pretty much because i
can then
solve the problem by polynomial
time on this guy typically linear as you
would see so from a practical point of
view
you give me a problem in this class
let's say one of these guys here i
write out a boolean formula through a
reduction and then i compile this
boolean formula
into a circuit of attractable type and
and i'm basically done so we're going to
be talking about
uh in just a little bit about the four
prototypical problems for these
uh we're gonna spend most of the time
talking about tractable circuits the
properties and all of that
i'm going to show you a core reduction
later uh which
which is behind a lot of reductions that
happened later it's pretty simple pretty
intuitive to bridge those two worlds of
numeric and symbolic and
we'll also towards the end talk about
the compilation process now
in connection to tractable boolean
circuits there is the story about
attractive arithmetic circuits
and as you'd see there's two tales or
two ways to describe arithmetic circuits
uh one of them uh will be as a side
effect of the first story so when i have
a tractable boolean circuit like this
one
you can do two things with it what you
would probably expect which is
purely symbolic manipulations but you
can also do numeric computations based
on this boolean circuit roughly it would
take the form
instead of passing boolean values zeros
and once to the circuit i can start
passing numbers
and then what does that mean well we'll
end up multiplying at n nodes
and and adding at all nodes so we end up
synthesizing an arithmetic circuit
that's doing that computation
now this part of the story will emerge
as we're doing the boolean
retractable circuit story
but what happened is as you'll see
these type of arithmetic circuits were
picked up big time on
in machine learning and probabilistic
reasoning and
while the story that we hear initially
is purely computational that i'm using
this as a computational device for
example one of the pictures that with
the measures we go on you'll see that
you take a promising graphical model
like a visual network and effectively
synthesize an arithmetic circuit that
allows you to do computations
on that probabilistic model and linear
time on the circuit side so that's
that's the story the computational
story but what people started doing is
they started handcrafting these
arithmetic circuits and even learning
them from data so bypassing the notion
of
a model that i'm trying to do
computations on and that demanded an
independent
treatment that's different from the one
that i'm going to be giving you
initially so we're going to get to that
later now this is the agenda it looks
big but some of these elements are
pretty short i'm going to just start
with a couple of words of complexity
classes basically the prototypical
problems for these classes that we
mentioned
and most of the time will be spent on
tractable boolean circuits because
really that's the essence of a lot of
what's going on
as i promised i'll show you the core
reduction that bridges the two worlds of
probabilistic numeric
and then we'll talk about tractable
arithmetic circuits
knowledge compilers award unexplainably
high again that seems like a lot
we'll see how much we'll finish but some
of these components are pretty
brief now let's start here so that we're
all on the same page as far as
at least what are the four classes of
problems we're trying to solve here
so i'm again i illustrate these even
though they're typically done
on boolean formulas i'm gonna show them
on boolean circuits just because it's
pictorially more
appealing so we have a circuit like this
with four inputs
uh on and off and as we know the
simplest
problem is sets right so is there a
circuit input
under which this circuit will generate a
one output we know this is set it's np
complete now the second
class the problem is i'm now going to
ask you if
the majority of circuit inputs satisfy
the circuit right so there's 16 possible
circuit inputs in this case and it's
nine or more
of them will satisfy the formula as we
know that is
mesh sets right and that's the
prototypical problem for the class bp
and the next two classes actually
require that we divide the inputs of the
circuits so you have to pick some
partitioning of the inputs in this case
let's say y and z
and here they are and
the first one says can you fix
the y inputs is there a setting for this
under which the majority
of the inputs are satisfying all right
and that is image set that's np to the
ppe
and you can probably guess what the last
one is right the last one
uh so this is is there an instantiation
of this under which the majority of that
the next one would be are the majority
of y inputs such that
under each one of them the majority of z
inputs
satisfy and that ends up being mash mesh
set and that's vp
to the pp now as i said of course
everybody's very familiar with sad this
is becoming
quite familiar these days these are
pretty actually
important and maybe you'll get a sense
of them when i show you in a little bit
the problems in prostituting and machine
learning that
are kind of prototypical for these
classes but
before i move on i want to mention two
variants on mesh set
because those are very important
practically so these are all decision
problems and what we're going to see
in the deductions we'll be talking about
functional problems so
uh okay these are the four uh
probabilistic reasoning problems we're
gonna look at them
shortly for mass at
is the majority of inputs such that you
know are there a majority of inputs that
satisfy the circuit
uh you can actually count those right
and that's not a short set or more
accounting i want to count i want a
number not just a yes no answer but
even more importantly from a practical
point of view
is uh the weighted model counting
version of sharp set so in this
situation what i'll do is i will assign
weights to
every variable setting so if x is zero
that's a number of weight
uh a positive number uh
if it is one that's another number
greater than equal to zero and so on and
now when you have weights for
these literals then you can assign a
weight for an input
to the circuit and and we do that by
multiplying the weights of the
corresponding
variable settings all right and now i
can tell you okay i want the weighted
count of the circuits input that
generator one and that's known as
weighted model counting or wmc
right so uh i don't assign a value of
one for each satisfying input
but there is a weight and that's the one
that actually gets used quite a bit in
practice and it is
important enough that i'm going to
visualize it differently so instead of a
circuit i have a boolean formula now
and these are the four very three
variables and these are the different
settings of these variables and i have a
weight attached to each one of these
guys
and then i'm asking you to sum the
weights of the satisfying assignment and
it's important to realize here that
these weights are induced
by literal weights right otherwise i
would need an exponential number
to specify the problem uh no in this
case i need just a linear number of
parameters
uh these uh literal weights so wait for
a wait for not
a and you'll see that later how it plays
a role in the
reductions so um
these are the problems we're gonna be
looking at or these are the prototypical
problems
for these classes and let me just
quickly just give you a sense of what
these guys are
and see how interesting again you're
familiar probably with these maybe these
are not as familiar
and these three queries mpe mar
and map have been around for decades i
think they're all in yuda pearl's book
from the 80s this one is pretty
recent from about 10 years ago let's
take a quick look just so that we have a
have a sense of what we're going to use
uh tractable circuits for bayesian
network as you know is
a graphical model it specifies the
probability distribution and
one query is in this case we have a
condition
we have two tests that wear on that
condition one of the tests depend
on the gender of the patient and this is
just a hypothetical notice saying
whether the two tests came out the same
i'm not showing you the whole bayesian
network but one of the questions you can
ask is you come and say someone
did the two tests and they agreed they
came out the same i'm not telling you
how they came out but they came out the
same either
positive or both negative and you're
trying to find
the most likely state of the variables
under that
evidence all right so you find the most
likely state
of the state of the variables and that's
called an mpe
or a most probable explanation mpe and
here you see the answer
c being no sex female both negative
that's the most likely state of that so
the decision version of this is there an
instantiation whose probability is
greater than
some threshold that is actually np
complete and the the next one
is the ppcomplete version which is known
as more and competing marginal
properties that's kind of the more
classical
query just compute the probability i
give you the fact that this guy
came out positive this is negative what
is the probability that the person is
immediately
okay competing that probability again
the decision version of this is pp
complete and the the next one going
up the hierarchy the map
map is actually very similar to
uh mpe except i'm optimizing over a
subset of the variables
so i want the most likely state of a set
of variables given
some evidence but you get to choose
those variables it's not all of them
and interestingly enough while
optimizing over all variables
is np complete this guy ends up being np
to the complete this is harder if you
get to choose the variables and optimize
the subset of the
original ones
as i said these three have been around
for a very long time bread and butter
they underlie a lot of
things that goes on the next query is a
little relatively recent about 10 years
ago
another question on your previous slide
so if you go back so
so uh what what's the input that i i get
i i get that the
the red thing is the outcome and you
also told me the blue guys that you're
interested in no
you give me the bayesian network you
give me the you give me the evidence
that i know that they agree that the two
tests came out and you choose the
variables that you want to optimize over
yeah these two guys and what i give you
back is this
i give you back c is no and sex is male
that's the output
okay so i'm telling you this is the most
likely state or the most likely state of
these two variables
under this particular evidence you call
it
thank you all right very good um
you know sometimes people enjoy they
call the state estimation
um and and this is partial state
estimation mpe is full state estimation
very good
now the next one is pretty interesting
uh now
if and it's been actually receiving
quite a bit of attention recently
uh you know if you look at these
bayesian networks they're usually used
as classifiers so this is
a bayesian network where uh i have three
tests urine blood
scanning and i'm trying to detect
whether someone is pregnant or not based
on these results so
uh typically compute the posterior on
pregnancy and check against threshold
and then you get a yes no pregnant not
pregnant so in this case let's say the
the
threshold is 90 and all you know is that
the scanning test came out
negative so the probability of pregnancy
is 40 percent that's below very sure the
decision is no
okay now what is the query the query
again you pick up set of variables in
this case we pick up
urine and blood you pick them up as as a
user and you tell me
what is the probability that my decision
will stick
even after i observe these two variables
and in this case the sdp saying decision
property is 78.7
that is right now the decision is no
not pregnant given this and now what i'm
telling you is if you were to observe
these variables
the probability that your decision will
stay the same is 78.7
so it's kind of an expectation sdp is an
expectation
and uh you can imagine how practical
this
is because i can use this to tell is it
worth getting some information or not
what's the value of information that i
can get from the circumstances
and the decision version of this vp to
the ppp complete and interestingly
enough as i said
all of these problems now that i showed
you can be solved by taking the bayesian
network
writing out the boolean formula i'm
going to show you how later
compiling that boolean formula to a
circuit boolean second of an appropriate
time and if you succeed
so the only bottom neck from a
computational point of view is that
compilation
if you succeed in the compilation then
you can solve these problems in
linear time linear in on the size of the
final
attractive circuit that you got okay so
it's pretty exciting
well let's see what these guys are
you know these are uh intricate problem
uh rich complexity classes and what
you'll
see is for each one of them pretty much
we know of us
of a property on boolean circuits that
unlocks those classes and those problems
so the story of tractable boolean
circuit
that we'll be painting uh can be
summarized in a picture that looks like
this so
we have a boolean circuit and we're
going to start with a basic type
it's called nnf circuits i'm going to
show you this next
and then we're going to start adding
properties these are example properties
these are not exhaustive and we're not
going to go over all of these but
when you add properties on these nnf
circuits you start getting different
circuit types some of them are familiar
obviously these are very familiar and
some of them are probably less familiar
and in fact this is the weakest type
here and as you go up here
except for this here the more properties
you add
two things happen you get more
computational power
more queries become uh polynomial time
on the circuit but then the circuit size
gets
larger right so there's this study of
three dimensions
what are the properties what do they
enable in terms of computation and what
happens to the circuit sizes
that study happens now in ai under the
label of the
knowledge compilation map so there is
this notion of attractable circuits and
knowledge compilation
and let me say a word here it's
important in in
ai traditionally knowledge compilation
has not been tied to the notion of
tractable circuits knowledge compilation
was just about
you give me a boolean formula i want to
answer something let me compile it into
something
that facilitates that computation but as
of about two decades ago
with starting with this paper there was
a
systematic picture about compiling into
tractable circuits
uh that that will describe next that has
been evolving over the last two decades
and then there was a stronger connection
between knowledge compilation and
directive circuits so
most of what's happening today on
knowledge compilation is about compiling
boolean formulas into tractable circuits
all right
the word knowledge compilation is
somewhat broader though uh sometimes
you'll hear me talk about this as
knowledge compilation
sometimes tractable circuits and i hope
you understand what's going on
knowledge compilation map is the title
of this paper which provided the first
picture of the type that i'm going to be
mentioning next okay let's let's move on
generally
question yes so when we say that these
are polytime then you mean that that's
polynomial time
in the size of the final compiled
exactly and of course you may not
succeed in getting that circuit that's
actually
what you'd see next it says how simple
this whole
formulization is really pretty intuitive
and simple but the real bottleneck is
the compilation and that's one of the
values is that
i'm squeezing the whole computational
game and turning it into one game
take a boolean formula convert it into
or compile it into a circuit
with the following property that i care
about and that's going to be the essence
of computation
everything is reduced to that we don't
need to do anything beyond that
as far as computation uh as we would see
there's a question in the chat also from
ryan williams so
uh if i only have to approximate all
probabilities up to say you know point
minus
zero point one point zero one percent
uh as error as the bayesian network app
seems to do
are these problems still so hard
complexity wise
probably not more like zpp to the np i'm
not going to get into that frank
everything i'm going to be talking about
here is exact but maybe towards the end
of the discussion i'll tell you about
some weakening of these properties that
i'm going to
talk about that could be the basis of
approximations
but everything i'm going to be talking
about today will be exact
um okay good thanks
all right so the basis of these
tractable circuits is negation normal
form circuits
so what are these you have three types
of gates and ores and negations
inverters
with a condition inverters can only
appear next to inputs
so you have inputs or inverted inputs
and then layers of ands and ors
now if the inverters appear within the
circuit you can always convert it to a
negation normal form of circuits while
doubling the circuit size at most
doubling the circuit side well
everything we're going to be looking at
will be
nnf circuits layers inputs or negative
inputs and then layers of hands and nose
and
and now what we're going to be doing is
in the next part of the talk
we're going to walk through a set of
properties
so nnf circuits are not interesting you
can do anything with them
they're not tracked but as we start
adding properties
we're going to start getting more and
more reflectibility and
circuits get bigger for each of the
property i'm going to
mention it in two ways pictorially which
is a very quick way of doing it
and then i'll try to see what happens
algebraically under it because you'll
see that each one of these properties
correspond to a certain type of boolean
function decomposition
so let's start with the first one the
simplest property is the composability
and this property is simple it's a
property that every and gate has to
satisfy if you look at an and gate and
you look at the sub-circuits feeding
into it
i i want these sub-circuits not to
overlap in terms of variables so if you
look at the sub-circuits lk
the circuit p-a the variables do not
overlap now this looks like a tree it's
not actually
it's a circuit because you can see the
variable p appear here and appear there
but we're laying out this way for visual
clarity
that's decomposibility it's very simple
and gates
the sub-circuits feeding into them
shouldn't share variables and
now sat is linear time on this guy okay
and and you got yourself np by this
simple property the circuits that result
from this property are called dnf
circuits
all right and if you look what's
happening algebraically
uh here's what's going on i'm basically
telling you i want you to decompose a
function like this one
this way now we know that
if you have a function that is a
disjunction of a number of sub-functions
we know that this is set if and only if
one of these is set
but something else is going on each one
of these subfunctions is decomposed this
way
so not only is this set when the first
the second or third either of them is
set
now i can decompose the sat on this guy
into two separate set problems of this
and that
because these guys do not share
variables so
because of this decomposition that's
induced by the nnf circuits now you can
say
sad f if and only if right and
and similarly you can take these set
tests and decompose them
and that's what you can get this in
linear time all right very simple
first property let's look at the second
property that
gets us to the next class together with
it with the property called smoothness
i'm going to mention smoothness next
smoothness is a convenience property
it's not
computationally important but
determinism determinism
is a property on or gates and
basically it says that however input you
apply to the circuit
no or gates will have more than one high
input
so high here is red law is blue
i set all variables to high you can look
at this or gate exactly one high input
too low this guy has too low that's fine
you can never have more than one high
input for any other
gate if you take this as alpha beta
gamma it's saying that the mutually
exclusive that's basically what
determinism is
the the composability is a structural
property this is more of a logical
property
if you have decomposability and
determinism
together you can do uh
match search upside weighted model
counting uh in polynomial time if you
have smoothness you can do it in linear
time i'll show you what smoothness is
next
and let's take a look of why can i so
now i can count now i can
count the models satisfying assignment
of a circuit in linear time so
and i'll show you this in just a second
how you can do this but let's take a
look at what's going on here
so this is the composition we've seen
earlier i want to count the models of
this i cannot add up the
the models of f1 f2 f3 but
determinism ensures that they are
mutually exclusive
so i can add the count of this the count
of this account of that
to get this and together with the
composability to count the models of
this
guy i can just count the models of that
guy and multiply by the models of this
so now i have a decomposition and now
you can see why you can do this in
linear time
almost almost this equation is not uh
technically correct for a subtlety that
i'm going to show you almost correct
you need something called smoothness
which is a property that says disjuncts
must
mention the same variables what does
that mean because that
ensures that we're counting over the
correct number of variables so so let's
look at this f which is
a or b right and i'm writing this is not
deterministic
these are not mutually exclusive but let
me rewrite it like this
a or not a and b now it's deterministic
so in principle i can count this and
count that and add them up
not exactly yet here's a third version
of this
where i just here instead of a i say a
and b or not b this is true so i really
didn't do anything
but now it's smooth because here's a
disjunct and here's a disjunct this
mentions a b
this mentions a b similarly for that so
what's the significance of this now all
of these three
are the same but if you decompose the
first one by saying sat
on this guy is a sharpshot on this
chopstick and that you get the wrong
answer
because you're gonna get a count of one
here
and what i want to get a count of two
because i'm counting over the variables
av
so if you have smoothness that works
basically smoothness make sure that
every variable that you're counting over
appears in the formula uh okay i i just
want to mention it because
it's it's a property it can be enforced
in quadratic
time uh there was recent work in a
couple of years ago where people
like theory folks started uh an ai folks
found some more efficient ways of doing
smoothness but
anyways okay let's take a look at how
this works in practice
here's a circuit decomposable
deterministic and i want to count its
models
and it it ends up being very simple and
what i'm going to show you now is
representative of
many of the algorithms on practical
circuit they correspond to simple
forward passes of the circuit so to
count the models of this
you simply assign zeros or ones to the
inputs pretty much in this case every
literal positive or negative will get
the value one
and you just propagate multiplying at
and gates and adding up at four gates so
da da da
that's it nine so there's 16 possible
circuit inputs and this is telling you
nine of them satisfy the formula
and all you have to do is this just
forward pass on the
circuit so uh as i said most of these
algorithms are polynomial but actually
almost all of them are linear for
class algorithms and you can do a lot
more sophisticated things now even with
these two properties you can do marginal
counts
i don't want to just know how many
satisfying assignment i have
i want to know how many of them sets a
to true and k to false
now i have a lot more queries to answer
based on this circuit not just one query
i
in principle i have an exponential
number of queries now i can answer and
and
similarly you just have to zero out some
of the inputs
and again you add multiply and this
telling you out of the nine
satisfying inputs to the circuit two of
them have a true and k false now this
ends up being
important to compute marginal
probabilities with model count
all right so so that's the rest of
what's going on
if you have a box that can take a
boolean formula
and compile it into a circuit that's
decomposable and deterministic just two
properties you unlock dpp
and you can do now uh weighted model
counting so now you can actually solve
probabilistic reasoning on problems the
graphical models
pending the reduction that i'm going to
be showing you later now
you can see what's going on here i'm
using a boolean circuit to do an
arithmetic computation so
really here's what's really happening so
you can think
of having synthesized an arithmetic
circuit
and this story was told
a couple of decades ago
there is a lot that can be said on these
resulting arithmetic circuits
and one of them is not only they can be
used to do marginal counts you can
actually differentiate these and compute
partial derivatives with respect to the
inputs and that ends up being meaningful
they give you even more probabilistic
quantities
we're gonna get back to this but i just
want you to now in your head to see how
this story of boolean circuits is
synthesizing a story about
arithmetic circuits interactable
arithmetic circuits we're going to come
back to
uh later let's go to two more properties
which will give us more circuit types
and allow it to hit even higher
complexity classes
and p to the pp and pp to the pp
what these two properties that we're
going to talk about next and they're
pretty important
at least practically they've had a lot
of impact
one of them strengthened the
composability into something called
structure decomposability
and the other one strengthens
determinism and each leads to new
circuit types
structure decomposability says
okay i i want the composability to be a
little bit more principled
i i'm going to give you something called
a v3 what is a vt v3 is simply
a binary the leaves of which are your
variables and you can use any v3
i don't care okay this is one of them
and when what i want is for every and
gate i'm going to now assume that every
and gate also has only two inputs
and when you look at the variables an
and gate it should map to
one of these v3 nodes in the sense that
if you look at those variables they're
in the one of the subtrees
and the other variables are on the other
subtree okay so you look at all of these
and gates they conform to that v3 node
they're doing their decomposition in a
systematic matter following that
v3 you look here those also conform to
the v3 they map to one particular v3
node and they decompose
their inputs according to that you add
structured decomposability you can do
more and you also get
one more exponential separation so by
the way going from decomposability to
terminalism
there is an exponential circulation this
gives you exponential separation but if
you look at algebraically of what's
going on here
really what this is telling you i want
you to decompose your function or
boolean function or or with an
expression
recursively as follows i pick a split of
the variables
x y of your boolean function and then i
want you to write it like this
as a bunch of g components or x
components y component data you can
always write a boolean function this way
for any x and y
but then you need to know how to split
the variables the v3 tells you how to do
that so
what's happening here when i give you a
v3 i'm saying okay when you start
pick your x variables so that they're in
the left subtree of the root
and the y variables in the right
uh child of the of the roots and now you
can do this
and repeat so if you now want to
decompose these
y components now you go and basically
use
uh v3 node number two and this is your x
and y
so basically gives you a recipe for how
to decompose
your boolean function and just to give
you an example of what can be done now
once you have structured decomposibility
you can now multiply or conjoin circuits
in polytime you couldn't do this
based on the lnf's if i give you two dnf
circuits and i say conjoin them
while guaranteeing that the result is a
dnf circuit
we cannot do this in poly time under
complexity assumptions if you have a
structure decomposit you can do this in
quadratic time actually and with
additional properties we're going to see
that we can unlock more complexity
classes
if you want to visualize this
differently uh here's the composability
versus structural decomposability
in both cases g and h's do not share
variables but here
they're actually doing the split of the
variables in a systematic
fashion okay one more property and we
try to wrap up this part
here so
what we'll do next is strengthen
determinism right and
just like we strengthen decomposability
and we're going to do it by adding one
more property on x y decomposition
uh this is a type of decomposition that
i called x
y partition as opposed to decomposition
y because it is an x y
decomposition with one more property
which end up actually having all kind of
implications
so again you give me the boolean
function and we pick up how to split its
variables
into an x and y and we write it like
this now i'm going to distinguish
between the gh i'm going to call these
g's
primes and these guys subs y
because now i'm gonna require that the
primes are mutually exclusive and
exhaustive
so if you pick up any of these two
primes they conflict and
and they're exhaustive so they form a
partition
now why does that end up being
significant
uh well if
your subs are distinct
if the subs are distinct you do not have
two h's that are the same
then we call this a compressed x y
partition and that happens to be unique
so if you once you decide how to split
the variable of your function into x and
y
there is only one way to write one of
these expressions
that is compressed which basically means
that
this would lead now to canonical
circuits and
again we have and canonical once you fix
your v3 because look what happens you
give me v3
and then i start i want to decompose
this function into this
the the first node tells me how to split
x and y
there is only a unique xy partition
that's compressed
so i got this guy and there's no choice
on how to do this
and now i'm gonna take this guy and
decompose it further
and now i'm gonna i know how to split
the variables so now
that you know how to split the variables
there's only a unique complex xy
partition
so i'm going to get actually a canonical
decomposition
now once you have this property
the circuits that you get i call these
sentential decision diagrams or sdd
circuits
and you'll see why this name is pretty
interesting but
this circuit is actually
uh nsdd it does satisfy the uh
partition determinism property and if
you think about it it's actually made up
of fragments that look like this
right uh where i have a function and and
it's being decomposed as we've seen now
the g1 g2
g3 are a partition what does that mean
here
that means regardless of how what
circuit input you apply
precisely one of the g's will be high
and the other two will be low
in this case this is the high and the
other are too low under this particular
input
which means that this fragment is in
this case just passing the value of this
guy so you can think of this
fragment as making a decision it's a
decision node saying should i pass
h1 or h2 or h3 and the guy that gets
passed
is the one that has a corresponding high
prime
all right so that's why it's called
decision diagrams now why is it called
sentential decision diagram
because the decision that's being made
here is
made based on testing the value of an
arbitrary sentence
g1 g2 or g3 in contracts to binary
decision diagrams which as we'll see
next on the next slide is a special case
of this
where the decisions are being raised on
a variable instead of an arbitrary
sentence
so these are intentional decision
diagrams now
it turns out if you have an sdv
with that is uh based on an appropriate
v3 i'll tell you what that in
just a little bit then these circuits
can do match myself
in india so what does that mean is
if you're let's say your inter under
functional version
uh if you're interested in doing sdp
remember the sdp query on wager networks
which is what is the probability that my
decision will stick
if i were to observe these variables
if you take your bayesian network write
out the boolean formula as i'm going to
show you later
and compile it into an sdd circuit with
an appropriate v3
then now you can do that query in linear
time on the sdd circuit okay pretty
remarkable uh
now i i skipped how you do the email
sad class uh that requires another
circuit type that i'm skipping
but it's called a certain type of
decision dnfs
we can cover that much on this talk but
i'll give you a pointer later where you
can track uh
all of the details down but let me just
say something about obdd's because it's
important everything is as we know
very important some people would tell
you they're perhaps the most studied
tractable representation of boolean
functions what do they have to do with
this
well they're just a special case of what
i just showed you on the previous slide
if you are just for notation so if you
take a decision node like this in an obd
we know all
these they're decision graphs right the
sinks are zero one if you give me a
variable instantiation you start at the
top and you follow the edges
high low high high and then you get the
value of the boolean function but
they're actually just
circuits uh if you take a note like this
and you can think of it as just a
circuit fragment that's what's going on
a multiplexer depending on x being true
or false i'm choosing to pass this or
that that's that's actually the xy
decomposition we looked at
except in this case the primes are just
either a variable or it's negation in
our case xy decompositions were more
general
the primes were arbitrary sentences now
we're restricting them to
so in fact in fact there's two
interesting observations
if you use a right linear v3 or what's
known as a right linear v3 in which the
right child of every internal node the
left child is a single variable
you are forced to always
use x y decompositions in which the x is
just a single variable and that actually
ends up generating sdds that are obd so
the notion of partition determinism that
i talked about subsumes
cenon's expansion which underlies obdd's
again here in general expansion i am
doing exactly what i talked about but
i'm splitting one variable and
everything else here i'm allowing to
split the variables into any two sets
without a restriction on the counts of
these two sets and
it turns out that branching on sentences
as opposed to individual variables
leads to exponential separation so uh
stds are exponentially more succinct you
will have
boolean functions that will blow up for
over the years but will not blow up for
sdts and that's that's basically what's
going on
now just a word on this notion of
uh what what what's uh v3 should you use
now if you remember
in the problems for n p to the p and p
to the pp we had to split the variables
into x and y
and to solve these problems using sdds
you have to pick a v3
that is arranged in a certain way for
these x and y
um let me show it to you pictorially
okay you don't have to read this but
you need to have a node on the rightmost
path
where everything outside that is is x
and the rest is y so you cannot use just
any v3 you need a v3 that has a
particular structure
and that basically allows you uh to do
these problems we call this constrained
sdds we call the v3s constrained
uh the uh trees okay we're almost done
with this part
um let me just say a couple of general
remarks before we finish
uh this component so as i said i i just
exposed you to part of what happens
under the area of knowledge compilation
uh this notion of studying these three
dimensions of properties
computational power succinctness is
under what's known as the
knowledge compilation map which was the
title of this paper that basically
started this methodology
for uh doing
things this way there was a workshop
five-day workshop dedicated just to the
subject
in france about two years ago
uh there is a tutorial there that these
slides are actually this slide is from
it
that shows you an example of the
containment so as i add properties i
start going down
you can see obdd's has the strongest
type of properties
compared to anything else that we've
talked about today they give you the
most computational power but they also
really succeed
you can see some of what we know about
succinctness this means exponential
separation
decomposability at determinism you get
exponential separation
i gave a tutorial uh
last summer at the parts conference
theory conference and there was a paper
attached to it
extensive survey which uh
i i'll i'll just give you a pointer next
you can find that a lot of uh
pointers to knowledge compilers model
counters
this is actually the paper it's called
three modern roles for logic and ai it
has broader scope than i
talking about today but you'll find it
online
and you can use it to chase a lot of the
references on things
before i end the segment let me just
also mention that
even though these developments have been
mostly within ai there's been a lot of
interactions with other areas
as well and
just a couple of you know knowledge
compilation meets large combination
meets
it's basically tractable circuit suites
uh as well
now because i i don't have segment
towards the very end about knowledge
compilers i don't know how much
time we have when we get there so let me
just have one slide here before
so in case we don't manage to cover that
you can ask yourself okay so everything
now is boiling down to this notion of
taking boolean formula and combining it
into a circuit of an appropriate tab how
do i do that there's two classes of
knowledge compilers
bottom up and top down the bottom up may
be more familiar well actually they're
not familiar to people i guess in the
following sense so bottom up
is how obdd's traditionally have been
compiled if you're familiar with
uh something like card the main tool for
uh obdd's
it's based on uh bottom-up compilation
which is simply
you compile every ingredient of a
boolean formula and you just combine so
if you want to compile alpha and beta
you compare alpha you compile beta
and then you can join the two guys to
obds the reason you can do this is
obdd's have what what's called
an apply operation which is an operation
that can combine any two obdd's using a
boolean operator in quadratic time
you can do the same thing for sdds stds
also have
a polynomial time apply operation
and therefore for you can actually build
them
that that way both of these methods rely
so so tell me when it's so
straightforward you just take the
boolean formula
and start apply applying both of these
are canonical
in this case if you fix the variable
order you have a unique obd in this case
if you fix the v3 you have a unique sdd
so it all boils down to finding the
right
obd or write v3 and that's where all of
the work happens
now top-down compilers which is the one
i will
talk about if i had a chance work
completely differently
they are based on search algorithms like
you use for sat
or sharp sat except that they keep a
trace behind them so
you can take a search algorithm like dpl
or resource of dpl
and keep a trace very simple notion of
quick trace if we get to that part at
least i'll have to tell you what the
trace is and then you'll see that the
trace is a circuit
so by running these algorithms and
keeping trace they spit out
circuit compilations and the interesting
story is
there are variants of this exhaustive
vpl algorithm each one of them leaves a
trace in a different
tractable circuit class and there are
implications for this compilation method
because if i can establish the trace of
an exhaustive search algorithm exhaust
dpl
search algorithm i can tell you a lot
about its complexity because of what i
know about tractable circuits
reflections
and what can you do once you have these
tractable circuits okay
so i'll leave it at that and and just a
couple of words
the space complexity of these guys end
up being way better than that
uh these guys can work on any boolean
form
uh these guys typically require cnfs
because they're based on these stage
algorithms that typically are quite cnf
so there's
trade-offs between these guys okay what
i'd like to do next
is it was a quick i missed that question
actually i see now sorry about this so
the question about sdds and obdd's
uh are sdds more powerful than obdd's if
you're also allowed to use additional
variables
if users are allowed to use additional
variables
uh i can't recall immediately
result but i can suspect once you add
additional variables you can do all
kinds of things
typically
[Music]
i i can't recall immediately now
a construction um and there's an added
comment in the chat that the std
is the same as an orthonormal expansion
page 80 page 48 in boolean reasoning by
frank brown
anyway but yeah usually i guess like
once you have these extra variables or
extension variables then all bets are
off no
um yes i mean once i mean
you know additional variables is a very
powerful thing so
i yeah i can't record something
immediate
uh on that uh by the way there is an sdd
package which is open source
available from my group it's in c you
can find it online
it's called the sdd packages type sdd
packages yellow you can find that so
um okay so any other questions jacob or
should we move on
can i just follow up on my comment i
think what you're doing and then is just
having that v3 determine the orthonormal
expansion
so the sdd you get a different sdd if
you have a different v3 correct
the sdd is is determined by the v3
yes so i'm just pointing out that this
is
the you know it's the the orthonormal
expansion has been known for a while as
an uh extension or our regionalization
of
shannon bull expansion where you have an
also normal basis
to uh to decompose but i think what
you're bringing here is
the v3 that actually gives you a
particular sdd correct
right in fact the whole game of
compilation is finding the right v3 and
if you look at the sdd package
uh it's all about dynamically searching
for v3s
in a similar fashion that you find right
now
but since turns out the question is from
karem i i think remember karen we had
this discussion a while back in one of
the lobbies and it turns out that
i i it's not exactly what you're saying
but uh we i i i'll follow up with you on
this okay
all right all right very good uh
quick question could you remind us again
what a wee tree is
what a v3 v3 is simply a binary tree
that's it uh where the leaves are tagged
with your variables so
take your variables and arrange them in
a
in a three structure binary structure
that's it
all right full binary tree so here's
here's uh
v3 and as i said a special type of v3s
is the right linear one
now the one that is shown here uh that's
a vp as well but if you think if you
look at this
it's like a total variable ordering in a
sense and that's why when you use v3s
that are
right linear and construct an sdd you
actually get
an ob ddy because look what this guy's
telling you that tells you if you want
to decompose your function
start with the root split your variables
into a
and then bcd if you apply the xy
decomposition with that split
that ends up being the channel expansion
so this forces you
to always decompose your function using
bools or shannon's expansion right and
and then you always get so you get over
these as a special case
uh of sdds because they correspond to
particular type of
v3s but uh i showed you v3s that are not
writing here
before so v trees give you a variable
order
that you can use to construct your bdd
if they're write linear but if they are
not right linear they
give you a recipe for continuously
splitting your variables remember this
is what we're doing we're taking a
boolean function
and if you split its variables into x
and y
then you can do this what the v3 is
telling you is how to
split your variables of a boolean
functions into two sets at every step of
the decomposition
they are not a variable order they're a
more general notion of a variable order
there are at the time scheme
but one of the use cases could be that
they can give you a variable order as
well
exactly if they're like linear if they
have a certain structure
they end up giving you a valuable answer
so another question i had was here your
if i understand correctly going from
cnf's to circuits or circuits to
circuits right that's
what you mean by knowledge compilation
you know we're typically going from
boolean expressions
to circuits typically from cnf to
circuits that's what we're typically
doing
yeah and i wonder if a lot of this
how one could use this to inform
pre-processing in processing and
encoding
in the context of sat solving a lot of
this could be
useful if you were to go from say cnf to
cnn for example
is that that is not the scope here
because this is where we get into the
business of knowledge comparisons the
the idea here of knowledge compilation
is when i'm going from something to
something
the new guy i'm going to has to be
attractive in some sense
right so cnf2cnf is not of interest to
this
area because the the output or what we
call the target is
the source and the target the target is
not tractable so for knowledge
compilation to kick
in you need the target to be tractable
in a sense
right and and it's the other way around
you can use preprocessors for set to
help with knowledge compilation
and actually people have done that so
okay very good guys let me tell you the
core reduction this is interesting
this is so just a a question of water at
some point
half like halfway through we should be
getting a small break i think usually as
i don't know it now or slightly later is
a good time
and just let's do this reduction because
it's brief
and then take our break okay fantastic
that works jacob
okay that was it it would be a good
transition okay
core reduction folks uh remember this
picture uh
and the idea is you can take these uh uh
you know models and write the boolean
formula and then
then you like wait a minute how does
that happen numeric
boolean well you get to see now the the
how this works
i'll i'll show you the core reduction
that from two decades ago that i
proposed it was the basis of at least
another
half a dozen reductions over the
following decade and it's pretty simple
if you have a bayesian network like this
uh three variables a b
c you have what we call these parameters
these probabilities
and for a root node it's just
distribution for a node like this
you have a conditional distribution on b
for every state of
a so these are two distributions
actually four parameters but two
distributions one distribution another
distribution
uh similarly here we call these
parameters these are the real numbers
now
if you look at what is the distribution
that's synthesized with division with
the major network it looks like this
i'm not going to tell you why but i just
want you to see how systematic it is
so these are all of the variable
instantiations and what you're doing
here is for the probability
is simply for every variable you go and
pick up one of the parameters one from
here one from here one from there and
you multiply them
and which one you picks is the obvious
thing you pick the ones that are
compatible with that variable
instantiation that's pretty much
it so you can see here every probability
of a row is the multiplication of three
numbers
because i had three variables if you had
ten variables you end up
having multiplying ten guys the
reduction is based on a very simple
concept
for each one of these real valued
variables i'm gonna introduce a boolean
variable
all right so this has 10 parameters i'm
going to add
10 boolean variables in addition to the
variables of the bayesian network
and and you write out boolean
expressions that look like this i have
to apologize these instead of being a
given b
should be b given a c given a but look
what happened here
the a's and b's are from your bayesian
network and then these are the new guys
that i introduced i introduced one of
these for every
one of those and and intuitively what
this means is
that parameter is present because if you
look at this row
out of the ten three are present and
seven are missing
and that's what this guy's trying to
capture now by construction
and and this this yellow boolean formula
can be written out in linear time
it's you can see it's pretty simple uh
if this is true and this is true if and
only if that parameter is present
uh false and false if and only if that
parameter is present and so on
uh by construction uh the number of
satisfying assignment for this guy
is precisely the number of rows here so
this guy has exactly eight uh models
and by the way we're reducing this to
weighted model counting so the weights
are
all literals for these variables are one
the only literals that get a real value
is these guys they pick up their
corresponding number
and what happens if you look at any
model of this
boolean formula it's going to look like
this there is a portion which
corresponds to these variables
in this case this is essentially true
through false that's i think
for second row and a bunch of these
positive guys and negative guys and by
construction
the positive guys here will be precisely
corresponding to these parameters so
given this mapping of weights the weight
of this model will be exactly the
probability that you care about and then
you basically can use this to do
weighted morally
pretty simple all right now this is the
vanilla flavored reduction this is the
first reduction that took
uh probabilistic reasoning and and wrote
it as a weighted model counting problem
it's the one that used for the other
kind of problems
and let me just say one word before we
take the break
this reduction that i just showed you is
only specific to the topology of the
beijing network the more fancier ones
can do more things by utilizing the
values of these status
in particular if thetas are zeros or
ones you can do better
if some thetas are equal which
correspond to something known as
context-specific independence and
bayesian networks then you can even
write
more refined uh reductions and you can
basically compile them better and so on
so this is basically
there's actually a good survey from
you know now it's ten years uh on this a
whole
slew of reductions uh uh based on this
idea that i just
uh told you uh this kind of now the the
standard reference for this use of
waiting model county to do probabilistic
reasoning uh later i'm gonna give you a
link
or show you i taught a course on the
subject there's 35 hours about what i'm
talking about today and two of the
lectures are about reductions two hours
on what i just did now in in a few
minutes
uh this this course is online now so
uh this is the time for break jacob so i
don't know how long you want to take a
break
fantastic yeah what do we say is let's
say 10 minutes
10 minutes sounds great so then
reconvening at something like
44 minutes past the hour in whatever
time zone you're in
good all right fantastic thank you so
much all right
mm-hmm
uh omid can you still hear me is audio
back
um can someone confirm audio yes we hear
you well
very good thank you
so we'll start in a minute jacob right
uh
yes there was a uh comment meanwhile and
just regarding this representation so so
paul b was commenting that
uh for extra variables with obdd's they
would not help at all the minimal form
is canonical for a given variable order
and the extra variables would just get
minimized away and be skipped
and the same would be true for any any
representation that is
that that simplifies under restrictions
uh
very good and then there's a comment
from
karam that the sdd is simply an
orthonormal expansion does not diminish
its utility since there can be many
orthonormal bases the g
functions the question is how to get a
compact expansion
which i assume the v3 is used for
is it possible to find a minimal
expansion
question
by the way since we're here and this was
mentioned the beat
uh we're not going to talk about this
today the bottom-up compilation
but uh there should be a lecture
uh on this in in my class that i'll
point you to
if you look at obdd's uh people have
spent significant efforts to try to
search for
variable orders in fact if you look at a
package like cut
you'll find that the majority of it is
these heuristics and the zillion ways in
which you can actually
heuristically try to find variable
orders in the sed package
which i spent a lot of time actually
developing
i try to give primitives for people so
that they can explore
search algorithms very easily so you'll
find very high level primitives
that will take a vt and say rotate a
node left rotate it right swap
its children and then all of the
low level engineering that has to take
place as far as adjusting the std to
conform to the new v3 that happens on
your behalf
so it is set in a way where people can
explore new heuristics and algorithms
for the research very easily and i i do
hope some people
will or some of their students will try
to solve that i think we need a little
bit more
heuristics for beat research
because as you know like just like
obdd's the difference between a good v3
and a
bad v3 could be exponential as far as
the sdd size so
check out the the sdd package
which has both the user manual and uh
quick
start and so shall we start jacob
yes please go ahead very good okay
so with this segment we'll talk about
active arithmetic circuits and
this is actually an interesting story
because as i said there are two tales
there is the original tale
which i alluded to where uh
arithmetic circuits is a side effect of
attractive boolean circuits in the sense
that
uh i'm looking at something like the
bayesian network and then
i reduce it to a weighted boolean
formula i compile it to a tractable
boolean circuit of appropriate type and
and the kind of operations that i'm
doing on this boolean circuit
effectively induce an arithmetic circuit
so
uh that was the original story from
about two decades
but uh what we're gonna do now is
something a little bit different
and and and why is that um i'll tell you
why
we're going to cut out the middle man in
a sense
and and simply talk about the
relationship between evasion network and
arithmetic circuit
uh and try to tell a story that is more
streamlined why
because what happened is these circuits
while they were
originally introduced as a computational
device the machine learning community
picked on them and start to do other
things
which is they start to learn them from
data
they start to handcraft them so there is
no longer
a reference distribution and
that can lead to issues when you lose
reference
of the uh basically reference
distribution and there were
issues which demanded a new look at all
of this and i'll give you it's a pretty
short story
but not only are we gonna tell the story
with going
between major networks and arithmetic
circuits we're gonna tell it even more
abstractly i'm gonna show you the notion
of a factor which you're familiar with
the notion of a factor is
comes from probabilistic reasoning and
we're gonna talk about the relationship
between an arithmetic circuit and a
factor
and and we're going to give you the rest
of the story the upshot
of this story is beyond giving you a
more direct
uh semantics for what's going on is that
in the space of
these developments the last about 10
years ago there was a major development
which at least you know got me wondering
about things and we're going to find
the solution to that so what is a factor
a factor is simply
a table over some variables and a number
attached to each row on that table so
it's a mapping from variable
instantiations to
numbers and the idea is this could be
coming from a bayesian network so a
major network specifies one of these and
these are always exponentially sized
right
they are the ones also induced by
weighted model counting but
we don't care where this factor came
from what i care
is i have a factor and i'm going to
define two computations with respect to
it so
the mpe computation which is find me the
maximum row
that satisfies some events so you tell
me b is false and you tell me find me
the
the row that is compatible with b is
false and has the highest value
that subsumes that right because instead
this goes would be zero one and you're
trying to find
the guy okay now the marginal
probability
is i want you to sum the weights of all
of these rows that satisfy some
condition v equals false and you can see
the subsume these guys now again
why is this important because i'm gonna
now talk about only the relationship
between an arithmetic circuit and one of
these tables
now this table as i said
is usually represented implicitly
by a bayesian network which is not
exponential in the number of variables
or a weighted model counting problem
that is not exponential number of
variables now
the question that we're going to be
asking is when does an arithmetic
circuit
compute these quantities correctly in in
linear time and what we're gonna find
out
ourselves doing is defining
only two fundamental notions and asking
three fundamental questions
that we will see next listen and this is
an interesting complexity puzzle there
that's going to come up so what is the
first notion the first notion is the
notion of nac which we're going to
define it now
simply as a computation graph that has
multipliers and adders
and constants and these indicator
variables what are the indicator
variables
for every variable and value of it you
have one of these indicators so in this
case i have two boolean variables a
and b there is an indicator for a false
indicator for a true indicator okay
that's
that's we're not going to assume
anything except that once you give me
your discrete variables
that defines the indicators that's one
input to the circuit and then i have
constants and then multiply as an
analysis no other assumption
and and i just need one more notion
which is how do you evaluate a circuit
under some variable setting so if you
give me a
through b false or another setting where
a is true but you're silent on b
how do you evaluate that is very simple
we replace the indicators by zero one
and evaluate in the usual way so in this
case
if an indicator subscript is compatible
with the input it gets a one otherwise
is zero so here i have a true
one zero right in this case i'm silent
on b
so both indicators for b gets the value
one that's
oh that's all i need now here's the
thing
the thing is
if i give you one of these circuits and
i tell you
what factor does it represent or what
factor
is it trying to do computations on you
have to settle this question without
centering this question there is no
meaning for making claim about
correctness and this is one of the
issues
that was missing from the machine
learning uh literature treatment
or follow up on on what i did earlier so
we're gonna
once you define that once you define
what is a de facto what is the reference
factor then you can start asking the
second two questions
and say does the ac compute the
marginals correctly
does the ac compute mpe correctly now
how do you find out what is the factor
that is represented or
the reference factor it's very simple we
evaluate
the circuit under full variable
instantiations
so this is a circuit that is concerned
with two variables a and b
and i want to know what is the factor
that this guy is claiming to do
efficient computations on very simple we
go ahead and say let's set the values of
a
and b to these values and evaluate the
circuits we know how to do that
how to set the indicators when a is true
and b is true and we do that we get
three
okay we do it for a through b false we
get four
da da okay now this is my starting point
now i said okay
you're trying to make claims on the
circuit i know now what
factor we're talking about tell me what
are you claiming
okay this what i just told you the
obvious was missing and and people
had issues where say oh this circuit
does not compute this i modify it
and now it can compute this efficiently
in the process of doing this
they change the underlying factor so you
were having a hard time doing a
computation
now it's easy but on a different problem
all right because this was missing this
concept
now here's the first observation
if the only goal is to get a circuit to
compute a factor in the sense that i
just told you that's not interesting and
that's easy actually if you give me a
bayesian network i can always
in linear time construct a circuit that
computes the distribution
of the bayesian network and the sense
that i've mentioned the interesting
thing
is when we want to compute marginals
what does it mean to compute marginal i
want
the circuit to compute the right
quantity when i give it a partial
variable instantiation
so in this case if i only tell you a is
true i don't tell you anything about b
will this do the right thing now what is
the right thing we know
because we have the factor if you tell
me a is true
the value that i should be getting is
seven because there is two rows that are
compatible with a is two and i want the
circuit to be able to add them
will it do it okay well let's see if you
do this here
it doesn't you get an eight so this
circuit
does not compute marginals for this
particular factor now let me show you
another circuit
this circuit this circuit has the same
reference
factor right we can check it try uh at
eight ruby two it will get three at
a through b false will get four that
that it's okay
now this one however does compute
marginals correctly
so if you go and evaluate at only a you
get a seven if you evaluate it at b
false you'll get a 16. if you evaluate
it at
truth so you wanted to add all rows it
will do the right thing
what happened two circuits both have the
same reference distribution
one can compute marginals the other does
not what happened here okay let me show
you another query
the other query is mpe mp is remember i
want to find
the the role with the highest value
that's compatible with the particular
evidence in this paper
uh we showed that for circuit that with
the right properties we're going to get
to this if you turn the adders into
maximizers
and evaluate the circuit at a particular
input
then the number you're going to get
happens to be the probability or the the
value attached with the or the highest
value
so and and this result said even more
said you can go back to the circuit and
find the sub-circuit you start at the
top and you follow the children that has
the highest value of a max node
and for a multiplication node you follow
all of the children you get a
sub-circuit
and that circuit identifies also the the
identity of the row and
the value so let's take a look this
circuit computes this factor but when
you
move the at others to multiply it
doesn't do the right thing for the mpe
so what's going on here
okay here's what happens what happens is
if you give me an ac that computes a
factor in the sense that we mentioned
whether it actually computes mpe and
whether it computes marginals depends on
what properties it has
and guess what these properties are
decomposability determinism and
smoothness
you can define these on on arithmetic
circuits just like you did on boolean
circuits
decomposability and smoothness are
simply structural properties so
there is no difference determinism just
instead of saying
at most one true instead of
this you can say at most one non-zero
under
okay now there's two sets of results the
the salient results in this area
the one and the next slide that i'm
going to show you both results does not
appear in the form i'm going to show you
next
uh but that's the gist of what's going
on and let me just say
when the machine learning folks picked
on this they renamed determinism into
selectivity and smoothness
into completeness all right now
the first set of results is that if the
ac
is decomposable smooth and deterministic
then it will compute marginals and mpe
correctly
okay now the surprising result came
in 2011. i'll give you specific
citations for these papers
in just a second it turns out that if
the circuit is only decomposable and
smooth
it will also compute believe it or not
you don't need the
determinism now this is this is now a
puzzle because
marginals is like counting and this is
kind of suggesting that
i can count without determinism which is
weird we're going to resolve this puzzle
in just a second but
the original claim these circuits that
were both decomposable and smooth were
called spns and the original claim that
svns
not only computed marginals correctly
they're also completely correct and
that's never to be wrong
no you can't if you only have
determinism the decomposability and
smoothness
and an ac will compute margins correctly
but it will not compute mpe correctly
now later when people found out
the mistake they corrected it by saying
let's add again
determinism which they renamed
selectivity and then they talked about
selective spns and they said those
compute both marginals and
except that spl's are exactly
decomposable that there is no smooth
ac's and we knew this result from before
now here's the interesting thing the
interesting thing is
this fact that i can drop determinism
and i can still compute
margins and i'm going to say two things
about it one of them
is that adds to the intrigue that there
is an exponential separation
so there is a class of factors that
you can represent them
by polysize decomposable and smooth ac
so
so you can find spns for these factors
that are polynomial size but if you
insist on determinism they'll blow up so
there is an exponential separation which
is like
wow i can still compute marginals using
a circuit type without determinism and
that could be exponentially smaller but
here's the big catch
and this account that i'm just giving
you now is is recent compared to the
history of this area which is just from
a few years ago here's the catch
the catch isn't following and this is
important this is from it was
the biggest puzzle from a complexity
point of view
look at the factor a factor is
the numbers in that factor are specified
by these
literal weights which is a product of
literal weights i get this
now now if
you tell me i want an ac for
this factor that is decomposable
deterministic and smooth i can
always find one where the constants of
that ac can be restricted to these
literal weights
and in fact i showed you even a
reduction for that
so the question is just about enforcing
the composability determinism and
smoothness
i don't have to worry about weights i
know which ways to use
that no longer holds if you drop
determinism
if you tell me i want a circuit that
computes a factor
and it's only decomposable and
deterministic it's only the composable
and smooth but not deterministic there
is no longer guarantee that you can find
one if you restrict yourself to these
constants of the circuit
another way of stating this finding an
spn
that computes a factor may require you
to search for circuit weights
so it's not just a structural property
it's not just trying to impose the
composability and determinism
you have to search for weights another
way of looking at this
relaxing determinism comes at the
expense of having to search for certain
ways
now this already pre-empt the
the puzzle which is can i do can i use
this for counting
right in counting these are zero ones
right
and that means you cannot just restrict
your circuit to have zero ones you have
to
you can find a decomposable and smooth
circuit that computes model counts
correctly but
its weights cannot be zero one you have
to search for those
now this is very interesting from a
complexity point of view and
computational point of view is of the
puzzles
from atlantic point of view it's not as
much of a big deal because
people learn these things so part of the
game is to search for weights right so
uh to what extent you would be intrigued
by this result or not is to what extent
you're interested in these circuits from
a computational point of view versus
learning them
from data so uh let me just mention a
couple of remarks
on these things this area there's some
confusion about things and partly
because
the notion of ac's experience and
recently people start using the term
probabilistic circuits
they've been used in two ways one in a
loose way to simply mean computation
graphs with indicators constants
multipliers and others and in a more
specific way
to refer to arithmetic circuits was
particular properties so
the experts people who work very closely
with this they will take aces to mean
decomposable deterministic and smooth
spn
to mean this selective spns
uh is basically just ac's because they
have the same properties
recently people start using
probabilistic circuits as
an umbrella term um very interesting but
actually restrictive because these
factors do not have
to represent distributions they're just
mappings from instantiations to
numbers uh so there's really no
you know specific tie to probabilistic
reasoning but that's where most of the
applications are
and you can induce more circuit types we
didn't talk about psds
those are arithmetic circuits that are
based on structure decomposibility and
partition
decomposability so they have stronger
properties than these guys
they're just probabilistic sdds and
uh if you get into this area
yeah the machine learning functions
decreasing inside and
you'll see a hot fudge of things and
gets complicated by people keeping the
renaming things
uh focus on the properties um everything
that's happening is actually due to
underlying properties and
and pretty much every property we know
of there came from
the boolean side
let me just give you i promised some
citations because
uh if you look at the chronology there
the the original formal treatment of
arithmetic circuits in this context was
in this paper
this was the algorithm that introduced
the mpe finding the sub-circuits and
turning adders of the maximizers
this is the paper that said was the
first to say
let's not just use this as a
computational device let's try to
basically kind of
use them as a learning device and this
is the paper that actually drop
determinism
and introduce the idea of hand crafting
ac's
the discussion that i gave you is based
on this uh which is the
most recent uh for for a theory audience
uh this would be highly recommended
extremely formal tries to
really give a treatment of what happened
in the literature before
then and tells the stories of
you know the two things that i mentioned
so
let me see how much time i still have
very good
uh what i have is two more topics one is
i want to talk a little bit about
knowledge compilers and a few words on
explainable ai towards the
very end so
unless there are questions i'll just go
ahead and and
talk about this probably i have what i
think
25 minutes yeah i'll do maybe 15 on this
and five on the other
uh there are no questions in the chat
there's been a discussion about this
minimization that it's probably
np hard to minimize and then the
question is whether you can somehow if
you don't need
exact minimization what you can do
better but i see no
questions very good okay so
folks thank you so
knowledge compilers right i i showed the
slide before
and again
the idea is either bottom up top down
i'm going to talk a little bit about
this at least this part here is quite
familiar this is quite a similar
uh you know jack was saying there was a
discussion on minimization
check out how how sdds are minimized and
how this v3 search happens it's it's
pretty exciting but we're going to talk
about the top down
uh notion of compilation because it's
interesting
from a couple of months ago so the idea
is
i'm gonna take an exhaustive dpll
algorithm
and i'm gonna add add a trace to it i'm
gonna have it keep a trace
and then what we're gonna when we do
that we're gonna turn it into a
knowledge compiler
and the idea is the trace ends up being
the circuit compilation it's like a
rewrite for the input formula
this is not a theoretical exercise
we built the first compilers that way
and then we formalize this notion and
other people
i think the toronto compiler d-sharp was
based on taking sharpshot
and keeping a trace and then turning
into a knowledge
analyst compiler so the idea is very
simple pretty powerful though
what does it mean to keep trace so if
you look at exhaustive dpl what's going
on here you have a boolean formula like
this
and then let's say we're doing dplm
right so you take
x i'm trying to find a satisfying
assignment x is zero i get this
x is zero y zero and set then i try
y is one then i try z
so at this point in the search i found a
solution a satisfying assignment
if you're doing dpl you stop done i
solve the problem
exhaustive dpl i keep going
one of the reasons is i want to count
how many satisfying assignments so
you go and and you run to exhaustion so
i'm going to try x equals 1.
and then when you get y then
you try the and now i found another
solution
again if the goal is to find it simply a
solution i'm done again but no i keep
going to exhaustion so so now this is
determination three
after having run dpl to exhaustion
now what is the trace of this process in
trace of this process if you look what
happened here
that termination three is actually a
circuit to rewrite
of your input what happened here you
look at a node like this we've seen this
if you have this x if false go this way
to go that way you can think of this as
this little circuit fragment
that says um not
x and that x and that or
right so by systematically keeping a
trace
and recording it in this fashion i got
to rewrite so i compiled the formula
okay this is not an interesting
compilation because that's a tree
now you can do various things both
on the search itself and and how you
keep a trace which end up actually
giving you different circuit types and
different knowledge compilers so
the simplest is this notion of dealing
with redundancy when recording traces
so if you look at this trace it is quite
redundant right these portions are the
same
so let's try to not do that and you can
do something very simple
which is do not record duplicated nodes
so let's start with terminals
no duplicate set nodes no duplicate
unset nodes
that's easy to implement but now i have
still duplicates of these decision nodes
you know the obd literature tells us how
to do this very easily
there's something called unique you know
table so when i see something like this
before i create it i check if i had one
like it and if i did i just point to it
so i get that okay so now we're doing
keeping a trace of dpl and with a little
bit of
you know care in in recording the traces
well guess what
this is an obdd
we just compiled an obdb now
that's not how obdd's after legitimately
been compiled that's not how cut does it
over these
are done in a warm-up fashion and in
fact when this was first introduced i
think
that was why this led to new complexity
guarantees
using this technique you were able to
give
bounce on the time of the deconstruction
not just on the
its final size but you have to realize
that what happened here is the reason we
got an obdb
is that this was exhaustive dpl but we
fixed the variable ordering
which is not typically what you do so
when i was going down the search tree
i'm always visiting variables in the
same order
if you don't do that which is the normal
with exhaustive dpl then you get what's
known as
uh basically fbt fbts right three binary
decision diagrams so
now exhaustive dpl with
keeping a trace in the in the classical
fashion
or the the vanilla flavored exhaust of
dpl will compile fbtt's for you
by keeping it right now you can take
this further
so one idea that was introduced later in
these search algorithms is the notion of
components or component decomposition
cachet was doing this i think um
and and my secret to compiler they came
out in the same year uh
we're doing this notion and i'm gonna
get to that but let me just tell you one
more thing
about what happens here what you have to
do when you're doing this
in dealing with redundancy in this
top-down compilation fundamental notion
is that a formula cashing which means
that
if you look at a part of your search
here's an example
i came down to this node by setting x1
to this
x2 to this the formula simplified to
this under this variable setting
here's another part of the search space
different variable setting but then i
got
the exact same formula and i do not want
to recompile in this case because i
already compiled this guy so what you do
here is you basically
cache your formula you generate the key
from it cache it and when you come to
this point say i've seen this before i
don't want to do it again
so formula caching is very important in
particular part
of um you know this this game
and and the last idea is is the
component
uh cache a component analysis
and and the idea is in the process of
fixing your values you may disconnect
your
uh formula right and then what you want
to do is
spawn independent exhaustive dpl
searches and that moves you up in terms
of
the class of uh circuits you can compile
so
you have this guy here and you set a
to false i had four clauses i got two
now but they're actually disconnected
that is
they don't share variables you can
compile these separately
or if you're doing exhaustive tpl you
run exhaustively pll separately on each
and you get a trace from each and you
just conjoin these
and now basically i'm getting a trace
which
is weaker in terms of properties and
this will give you
um now you're going beyond that we need
to start getting
uh deterministic decomposing with
negative form actually even a specific
class of those known as decision enough
and i guess you you'll get the
idea of of what's going on so uh tomtom
compilation that's that's the basic idea
there's all kind of bells and whistles
there are limitations um
in the sense that these
will in a sense inherently generate
deterministic
circuits because at the essence of dpl
is you take it very well and say
through false right so you have
established determinism and even more
specific type of determinism
uh which is we call decision determinism
uh i had a recent relatively recent
paper with um it's on the archive which
shows how you can go beyond that but
i'm gonna basically finish the story
here
i have about a few minutes on
explainable ai just in terms of
pointers because and that's what i'd
like to end up with and then we can
probably have
a discussion um
and and just before i do that part uh on
explainable ai interactive
circuits let me say that that what we
just saw which is the notion of you take
a
search algorithm keep it trace you get a
circuit it has implications
because it's a technique for proving
lower bounds
that is if you give me an algorithm x
and you can establish that if traces
belong to this class of circuits then
then that has implications one
your algorithm x will explode on any
formula
that we know does not have a polysize
representation in that circuit
in in that class second if we know that
this circuit type
allows certain operations to be in
polytime then your algorithm can do that
as well
so i can infer positive things and
negative things about
your algorithm by establishing
the class of tractable circuits that it
traces
generally okay and and in fact there was
what i believe all
once apparently here he did show some
lower bounds um
based on that okay
what i'd like to end is with a couple of
remarks on explainable ai this is
something that i've been uh
doing a lot of work over the last couple
of years and
the the basic idea is this so i'm just
going to give you the the high level
intuition and how does
uh work on extended playing tied to what
we talked about
it's pretty intriguing just the big
picture and a couple of pointers and we
leave it at that
what a lot of what's happening in ai
today is is basically this picture where
you have data
and you learn a machine learning system
based on this data it could be vision
network classifier neural networks fire
random forest
but these guys classifiers are just
functions they make instances to
decisions
and and people now are interested in
answering questions about these boxes
long time ago we used to build these
boxes in a more
uh maybe model based fashion so i can
tell them what they're doing but now uh
i label data i get a box
it's not as easy to figure out what
they're doing people want to know
why did they make certain decisions are
they robust enough
proof formal properties do
they make bias decisions and so on and
and the main observation here is that
even though these boxes are numeric and
even though they're learned from data
the input output are typically discrete
so they're just fancy representations of
discrete functions
so the idea is we want to compile these
ml systems
their input output behavior which is
discrete into attractable circuit
that captures that input output behavior
and then i can actually
uh then do the analysis on these
tractable circuits of course this is
what i couldn't get
there's the area now mostly
uh not verification of neural networks
that's something similar not necessarily
by
compiling interactable circuits but
using other tools directly said solvers
and these underlying id is abstraction
input output behavior
is not numeric i can abstract that and i
can do various things
i usually use this example because it's
very simple about a youth-based
classifier
as to give people a concrete image of
what i just talked about
this is the features i'm trying to find
whether someone is pregnant or not
it's numeric it was learned from data
but it does specify a discrete function
the inputs
values of tests discrete variables
decision is yes no
i can use for example a decision diagram
and nobody need to represent this guy in
fact this obd does
uh match this classifier guaranteed
for any input output whether
you use the simple procedure on the obd
or whether you assert this as evidence
compute probability check against
threshold
guaranteed you're going to get the same
answer in both cases
so you can use this to do actually your
computing your reasoning
this picture opens up three questions
one
is whatever systems i can compile
what practical circuits which you can
guess you choose retractable circuit
depending on what kind of queries you're
interested in but it also opened up
a new path in the sense of what queries
are interesting so if you look at the
traditional knowledge compilation lab
and the work
the classical quiz i want to conjoin i
want to just join model counting
now when you start doing analysis of
behavior
you come up with new queries that have
to do with explanation
with robustness and it's not as obvious
of how to formulate these
so i give you the world in terms of
computation i think you can do anything
for three
but get me the right answer and you
don't know what's the right answer
so that opens up another dimension and
the line of work
over the last couple of years have been
looking at this
as far as compiling classifiers uh
major networks this original work the
example i showed you about the naive
bayes actions from a long time ago and
we did this nobody was paying attention
uh recently we
made this work for advertising networks
at least in terms of formalization
and uh very limited types of uh
finalizing neural networks and and
random forests can be combined
conceptually these are the easiest
because they're already actually almost
symbolic
these are the hardest conceptually
because in both the neural networks and
decision
factories and then the forest what the
input output behavior is already
forward there is nothing sophisticated
going on in terms of going from the
input to the output
invasion network's a completely
different story i give you a model
to find out what output the model will
compute given an input there's
very subtle things happening but there's
quite a bit of work in terms of
excuse me uh what kind of things you can
do in terms of questions there's
explaining decisions
there is uh quantifying robustness
verifying properties
and so on so i don't have time to go
over this here but i just want to
point to that there are questions from
sybil
in the in the chat does compilation into
a tractable circuit
also work for cnns or weighted random
force or balanced random force or you'll
take that later and wrap up what you're
doing now
so as as far okay let me do this i just
have a couple of more words and then
i'll get to this question i'm done sure
uh because i only did this part very
briefly
and there's quite a bit of work and i
think joao would be talking about
extendability later and he'll tell you
about the broader picture which is great
but
as far as doing the tractable circuit
compilation there is a recent
development from last summer and an
associated paper so if someone wants to
start somewhere for this particular
audience i would recommend this paper
and and this has to do with
explainability and the notion of
something called a reason circuit or the
complete
reason so if you give me a classifier
and you give me an instance then there
is a decision made on that classifier
right
so in this paper we introduced the
notion of the complete reason behind a
decision
and a corresponding reason circuit which
is attractive representation of word
and that reason circuit or that complete
reason it's a very interesting boolean
formula that if you have it
you can do a lot of reasoning about the
decision why it was made is it biased
not by it so it's kind of give you the
handle
on the logic behind why that decision
was made
and the interesting thing is for a
certain class of classifiers including
obds and decision dnfs
you can get that reason circuit in
linear time if you give me an
uh an instance and then you say give me
the reason circuit for the decision of
that instance i can
extract it from the classifier in linear
time here's a classifier as an obviously
this is the reason circuit and happens
to be monotone
so it cannot get any better and and you
can use this reason circuit for
all kind of things from answering why
the decision was made
is it bias and the paper is titled on
the reasons behind decisions
uh it was inikai 2020 you'll find a
whole section there that people about
what can you do once you get your hand
on the reason circuit but just as a
teaser you can use it to evaluate
counterfactual statements like the
following
so susan was admitted by classifier and
then there's this even if because
statement
susan would still be admitted even if
she did not have a high gpa
because she passed the entrance exam and
comes from a chant on pretty subtle
statement
you'd see in that paper how a statement
like this can be evaluated
uh based on the reason circuit behind
the decision so
uh i'll leave it at this i did mention
that i taught the course this fall
there's 35 hours
of material on the subject starting with
some basics on boolean logic and set
solving and so on it's on
uh on youtube and
you can get to it uh and other things
from our youtube channel
just type ucla automated the reasoning
group you're gonna get this page you're
going to see
this course and up there you're going to
see software
and publications and and so on so
thank you this is pretty much all i want
to say and it looks like i'm
on time so jacob let me start with the
question you asked so sorry i i had to
uh believe it so there's the question
can you repeat it again jacob
the question was does compilation into
a tractable circuit also work for cnns
what about weighted random forests and
balanced random forests
very good now so at least what we've
done so far for the compilation
uh now we only did for neural networks
binary inputs and step activation
functions
we did actually compile something that
resembles cnns
but where we basically
looked at the binarized version because
one of some of the examples we reported
on
were related to recognizing digits and
images black and white
and to to get uh you know
neural networks that have good accuracy
we basically had a kind of a
binary version of of cnn that we combine
this is very very
baby steps there when you use other
methods not compilation you can
definitely scale a lot better
for random forests we only did a
majority voting
the the and that's kind of a steadily
straightforward
encoding because as i said the random
force are almost i mean they have
numbers
but these numbers are used in a binary
fashion so you have a decision that says
if x is greater than 3.7
that's a binary condition x is greater
so you you take your x and discretize it
and then you're in the discrete world
and the good thing is you don't even
have to discretize the learning
algorithm did the discretization for you
so it's you're almost there
uh but again there's more sophisticated
encoding especially with folks that
not just compile but actually use more
general tools and i think chua will
probably talk about some of us
comes up later
i hope this answers the question
any other questions so sibila says thank
you in the chat so
yes and that's the comment that in
balanced random forest samples are drawn
non-uniformly
uh any other questions people are free
to unmute or ask in the chat
so uh hi uh could you just say a little
bit
more about the uh partitioned std case
because that's
that's what you need to get this pp to
the pp
type problem uh rep uh
efficiently is that correct right so
uh you mean constrained sdds well
portrayed as tds
yes so so what happens there is that
result and that's
um the the paper let me get there
oh okay oh that's just the constrained
one sorry
yes yes yes all right so this is the
paper with um
stock and uh you need a special type of
retreats
because as you know to even define a pp
to the pp problem
you need to split the variables into x
and y right
and what the the way the x and y
influence
things is they constrain what kind of v3
you can use you have to use a particular
type of v3 not any v3 so v3 in general
is any binary tree as long as the leaves
are in one
to one correspondence with your
variables and as far as constructing an
std any of them will work
but of course some will lead to smaller
or bigger sdds but when you want to use
it
for ep to the ppp for computing
expectations
you would need the v3 to satisfy a
constraint based on what you choose to
be your x and y
variables okay thanks yes sorry
and and and the paper is uh this is the
paper
uh stock uh in kr 2016 has all of the
details on this one
thanks one other comment just on this uh
terminology things with arithmetic
circuits and spns and
you know whether what's decomposable in
some ways it would actually be better
to have a terminology that's more like
the nnf thing with the
where the the specific restrictions are
explicit because of course arithmetic
circuits have been around since strassen
in the
in the 1960s studied on the theory side
and
as some product networks doesn't really
re name either doesn't reflect the
restrictions so
just we should we should come up with
one name that
that everybody kind of agrees on i
agree and the only temporary solution i
have for this and
when i teach i tell people because i get
a lot of people who's
really confused and and some of them are
not just students by the way some of
them are researchers and i say here's
the guide
go by the properties so yes we have
messed up as far as
naming the final creatures and and
there's a lot of confusion
but the properties are very clear and
the implications of the properties are
very clear
so anytime someone tells you i have a
new creature says let's wait to see if
it's new or not
what are the properties and for now but
i agree with you completely
uh you know paul and starting with the
term arithmetic circuit was not the
greatest
choice but that's what happened so
all right any other questions
there is nothing in the chat let's see
people let's see feel free to ask any
questions or unmute
and just speak your mind
all right same thing yes
wait so is there one more question
coming it just says one more in the
oh is there a general technique
to show exponential separations between
these forms they vary
but some of the more interesting ones
and paul is an expert also this is
communication complexity in fact one of
there was a separation
between the decomposable and
decomposable and deterministic and for a
long time it was predicated
on a complexity assumption and then
folks then used some results from
communication complexity to actually
show heart separation there
it's it's a fledge of techniques uh but
uh
um some of the latest and and sharp ones
uh were based on what's known in
communication complexity and and i think
paul did some of these as well
wants to ask a question let's see if i
managed to unmute her
oh uh sibila can you speak i think you
should
okay okay i will find muted but um well
on my headphones i still was muted so uh
one question
maybe it's a trivial one when you speak
about knowledge compilation so you have
a cnn formula then you do this
exhaustive dpl search then you have this
um
circuit or other kind of language
however
you you call it it is only for this
specific formula right
uh yes the the you're just compiling
that specific formula
and this is a a good point to say
something
so typically this is worthwhile when you
then have a whole bunch of queries on
that formula
so if you you just want to compute the
model count
um you know that's not typically what
people use this sometimes you want to
compute a lot of model counts so
what is a lot of model counts it's just
one formula it has one model count
it's the marginal counts so how many
models are
have a through b false and these
marginal accounts there could be an
exponential number of them so when you
do the compilation then you use that
compilation very efficiently to answer
an explanation above queries and that's
what happens with probabilistic
reasoning
you're competing then marginals for
different pieces of evidence
everything becomes linear at that point
so which is great
yes just when i heard it the first time
or obviously i said well it's a noise
compiler i can
translate but of course it doesn't work
now
obviously it's clear but in the
beginning it was just a bit misleading
but if i now um as a i do exhaustive dpl
or cdc or whatever search and i can
create some
dnf with disjoint um
cubes then i could also call this a
knowledge compiler i don't record this
the search tree but just this unif
i mean the search algorithm with the
trace is what we call a knowledge
compiler because it's
it's rewriting your input
in the chat for which of these uh do we
know the complexity of computing or
approximating minimum
size which of these forms uh
i i i okay uh okay maybe i'm not the
best person uh
the complexity of compilation here
marquee would
probably be so obdd obd i guess i don't
know that we've added
much to what's now this has been
discussed for a very long time
there has not been a focus for me
frankly i i've nothing immediately come
up
as far as this is called
compilability right this is the
complexity of really doing the
compilation
process itself
i mean you're lower bounded but by what
you can do
after you got the circuit but this is
not something that i personally have
investigated much
so armin is writing these are all
boolean
decision diagrams is the room for
algebraic decision diagrams or even
moment diagrams
so all right so boolean discrete and
there is the
probabilistic versions now you can right
so if you look at
uh what happened with obdd's and how
people will generalize them and so on
uh there's quite a bit actually people
did that so let me just i'm glad i'm on
this particular slide now
this is a snapshot
there is a lot more than what i talked
about and in france in particular
there's a lot of
variations and it may include some of
what armin
uh is asking about i think and
the group and to lose so there's a lot
more i
i gave you just a flavor of maybe some
of the salient
circuit types but when you talk about
what people now say knowledge
compilation map
there's so many extensions and many more
circuit types that were studied
and yeah this is just really
subset of it and in particular you know
mostly what i've introduced or worked
closely on
the interesting thing about the notion
of a knowledge compilation map is beyond
the initial at least the original one
beyond the set of circuits that it
analyzed it's the methodology
right so the fact that before that there
was no
you you you were not kind of expected
to answer that many questions when you
were to introduce a new creature and say
i'm going to compile them to this after
the knowledge compilation map it stand
it established a norm of that you have
to tell me something about the
succinctness you have to tell me what is
in now possible in poly time if i
compile into this guy
and can you tell me something about
succinctness and then after that you
could start doing actually this these
reporting results in this form you tie
to what exists by talking about relative
success to the extent that you can
what is enabled by it uh which was
interesting
so but again there's a lot more going on
than what i
you know portrayed today
okay thank you so much
you know thank you everyone applause on
behalf of everybody
very good very good thank you guys and
pleasure to participate today okay
thanks a lot bye
you